Covid-19 is a disease caused by a virus,...
...which belongs to the family of coronavirus.
This virus is the one that caused a pandemic in 2020.
A pandemic is a new disease that spreads all over the world...
...and affects many people.
So far, we have observed that this virus can spread very easily via vectors...
...like objects we have touched through sneezing or coughing.
This can cause many people to get sick during the process of transmission.
That's why the disease has spread worldwide.
As you know, the important thing now is to look after ourselves and others.
That's why many measures have been taken.
To avoid the spreading of the virus,...
...it is advisable to follow some hygiene standards.
Wash your hands very often or use hydroalcoholic gel.
Did you know that this way the material that envelops the virus is broken?
If this material is broken, the virus can't infect the cells.
Be careful with the objects you touch...
...and avoid touching your face.
Keep a safe distance from others to protect yourself and them.
If you use a mask, be careful not to touch it once you've put it on.
The mask should cover your mouth and nose.
Cough or sneeze into your elbow.
Research is very important to be able to solve all our doubts.
Moreover, we should thank all those people...
...who are working and helping so that we can  get back to normal.
Would you like to be a superhero?
Follow all prevention measures to protect yourself.